well you may not think and you may not
know about tacos but Americans eat
billions of them every year
but Jose ralat goes above and beyond he
is Taco editor you know that's a job
it's a job I like that taco editor for
Texas monthly magazine and he's arguably
this country's foremost expert on the
Mexican specialty in a special Hispanic
Heritage Month installment of our series
the dish Omar villafranca joins relat on
the taco Trail in Dallas and he just
sort of well you'll see digs in
foreign
form the taco is a tortilla with a
filling
made from corn or flour
filled with beef or pork or even octopus
it's humble street food
and elevated fine dining fair but it's
so much more than that
it's grown to be one of the most popular
foods in the world and a way to
convey culture you know tacos are a
Force for good Jose ralat should know
he's the country's first Taco editor for
Texas monthly
much like the foodie writes about relat
is both down to earth he openly talks
about his stutter and highbrow he
recently won a James Beard award for his
work you just want a very prestigious
award that is usually given to people
who write about white tablecloth places
there's a legitimacy to everything
there is value in talking about what
people often overlook
and people Overlook Mexicans and Mexican
food all the time even the taco the
Puerto rican-born relax didn't grow up
eating the folding food but after years
in Texas the Taco's Temptation inspired
him to go head first into writing about
the Mexican Cuisine I was looking for a
way to not only tell
stories that were at risk of being lost
and
I want to play these
stories for my son because these are the
stories of his people
stories like those of Mexican immigrant
Rodolfo Jimenez he's a Lucha Libre
loving former telenovela actor who
brought his Guadalajara style fair to
mascara's Mexican Grill in Dallas
relat writes about how the beef biryan
taco saved jimenez's restaurant it
increased the sales like by 300 percent
but not only that now people knows the
rest of the menu and they come because
they know they won't find it anywhere
else did Instagram make the bdf.gov
famous
absolutely absolutely
a little dip in there dip
that insta-friendly dip into the bilia
OR stew is a distinctly American twist
Mexicans drink it it's not just eating a
taco it's almost like a little
experience a ritual yeah and I I still
prefer at the old-fashioned way in a
bowl
provolver's gastro
Cantina
it's fanciest tacos
but but they're still
traditional
since you need multiple sources on
stories
and since CBS was paying look at all
that food we tried another spot on the
taco Trail
everything we have here is eaten in
Mexico octopus duck tongue beef tongue
what are you gonna have first I'm gonna
go for this fajita because I have
ordered it several times and have been
told it has been sold out oh I like this
a CBS exclusive
this is excellent border food I'm gonna
try the octopus
it's not supposed to be
tidy and me
it's good
it's got the spices that you wouldn't
expect with octopus the taco the
tortilla itself is fantastic
when people try a taco like this that
they may not have ever tried
what does it open them up to hopefully
it teaches them that
just because
something is outside of their experience
it doesn't mean that it's illegitimate
relat says tacos tell a story and like
stories tacos have a beginning a juicy
middle part and an end meant to be
enjoyed over and over again
[Music]
for CBS mornings I'm Omar villafranca in
Dallas
good lucky else we get to try that
trendy Taco the beef Barilla it's not
from Texas but from a food truck right
here in the Bronx but I alendia so they
say you can either dip the taco in the
sauce or you can drink it like a soup
ahead of time during the story
I'm so bummed because this is the day
I'm starting my fasting that I'm
supposed to not eat before 11. but I
figure it's got to be 11 somewhere right
you and me both God did 100 sit-ups this
weekend and they are gone
I did try really good though this is
really tasty uh I love it um I gotta say
Texas monthly with a taco editor I'm
there for it Texas monthly is like the
best magazine in America right now it
really is so we have some for the crew
too do we so yeah
well I started eating
I started enduring the story because I
know how this works I get two bites and
then we gotta move on to the next door
and all this food goes away and then I
come out after the show and they're like
oh no that's all gone yeah it disappears
but this is very good